moi j'ai comme un peu par cas une
inondation j'aurais que le soleil in
bruges se trouve comme ça pourquoi
à cause d un bouquet d dedans et surtout
parce que moi je nomme je m'en vais
souvent montfort et bah moi je passe mes
marques dans quelles soient libres ils
ont peur peur pour les animaux qui
peuplent leur imaginaire ou pour l'état
de leur patinoire
faut dire que ces mots de grands
changements climatiques
c'est à ses parents est compliquée avec
les jambes dans le royaume de cette
enfance qui joue sur le bord du fleuve à
lévis madame geneviève comme l'appellent
ses élèves a décidé dans sa classe
on comprendrait un peu mieux pas pour
rien auquel je tiens beaucoup beaucoup
parce que c'est un projet qui parle de
l'environnement puis c'est quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur puis je pense qui
vous tient à coeur aussi on a commencé à
en parler entre eux peut donc paraître
très intéressant vous allez voir une
couche canto la planète de gaz à effet
de serre il fait aux deux pour ce faire
madame geneviève à éviter une autre
geneviève qui anime ici le premier de
cinq ateliers qu'elle donnera dans cette
classe de 5e année j'ai de mes présences
séance environnementale dans
biogéosciences de l'environnement de
l'université laval
je suis à la coopérative forêt d'ardenne
forêt d'ardenne c'est une coopérative de
mordus de l'environnement qui ont conçu
des ateliers qu'ils offrent aux écoles
mais surtout une bourse du carbone pour
enfants un petit geste à la fois le
concept est simple les enfants sont
encouragés à récupérer ayant marché
bref à y mettre peu moins de gaz à effet
de serre les crédits qu'ils amassent
sont revendus à des entreprises
polluantes
cela représente une centaine de
$ par année ce qui finance les activités
de la coopérative des agents de la forêt
d'arden vont donc dans des dizaines
d'écoles dans différentes régions du
québec depuis sa création en 2010
l'exercice effectuées par des milliers
de jeunes a eu un certain impact 12000
tonnes de moins de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère une tonne de gaz et
peut-être d'environ 3500 km fête en
voiture
donc si on si on dit qu'on est vite et
12000 tonnes ben faudrait faire la
multiplication de notre 3500 francs je
leur ouvre l'esprit est toujours à se
questionner à réfléchir à autre un pas
que leur gestion
puis ben moi je pense beaucoup qu'est ce
qu'on fait là on conscientise beaucoup
plus tard des fois je les appelle le
multi décideurs de demain
mais c'est pour aujourd'hui aussi parce
que duke et les petits s'éduquer les
grands ils vont concentrer leurs parents
aussi de façon plus informelle de la
faune plus juste en disant maman moi
j'aimerais ça marche et que ça ne
reconduit pour l'instant ce type de
cours et de projet repose entièrement
sur la bonne volonté des enseignants
mais cela pourrait changer le
gouvernement couillard dans sa stratégie
sur le développement durable a demandé
au ministère de l'éducation de réfléchir
à la mise en place d'un programme d'éco
éducation dans les écoles trop froide
pour houdré qui a suivi les ateliers de
la forêt d'ardenne il ya deux ans cela
tombe sous le sens
et si un peu à lui tout seul donc prend
soin de la planète
disons que c'est notre faute s'il ya de
moins en moins bien
ce sont peut pas dire c'est la faute à
personne c'est la responsabilité du
touch compte un conte paul piché cas
nous c'est justement pourquoi la
conférence de paris on consacrera une
journée au bol clic peuvent jouer les
écoles dans cet enjeu qui touchera avant
tout nos enfants